you look very lovely tonight and I
noticed you guys noticed a tattoo when
you came in do you have a lot you're a
bicycle there you have a lot of tattoos
I have I think it's 15 now you have 15
mm-hmm tattoos and they're pretty well
oh yeah so yeah I got a bicycle I have a
pig
I have a elephant I have a flamingo I'm
a but I have a lollipop ice cream cone
and a cupcake this as it's sweet just
tasted little asterisks and then just
sort of on your thigh it should say
unless you're diabetic it should be a
medical disclaimer all right so that's
that's one butt cheek the next one okay
what's on the other butt cheek chili
pepper this is muy caliente a lot going
on back there interested you know have a
little bit of literature back there
right
hey guess what do you oh how do you feel
about cancer because I feel like you
should have dinner with us I want to
know about
yeah it's war we're gonna raise money to
beat cancer initiative joining the
surface favor we're there at the day
room we're eating don't shout out I'm
gonna catch me a couple
I love it a really fancy restaurant hi
wait a bit of good Hubert was nothin
that's dessert
[Laughter]
you